Why did you start practicing Daito-ryu Aiki-jujutsu?
I was living abroad and because I am Japanese,
I wanted to learn something about my culture, my history
and since Daito-ryu is a Kobudo, it is grounded in history, that is why I wanted to start.
If you enter like this... here... nothing moves.
So just leave it like that, just put your hand on top of his hand,
leave it like this and don't mind him.
If he wants to strike, you can strike first...
and then do a Tai-sabaki first,
like this and it works.
I was practicing Aikido but had a lot of interrogation about this art.
There are a number of restrictions in Aikido that can be alleviated in Daito-ryu.
I was wondering things like: "Why doing things like this?", "How to do that?"
but I got the answers in Daito-ryu.
Let's take Aiki-age as an example,
In Aikido, Aiki-age quickly becomes Kokyu-ho, why is that?
What does this mean?
In Aikido, Kokyu-ho aims at performing the technique in the easiest manner for oneself.
But this is in fact the latest stage of a technique.
In Daito-ryu on the other hand, we start at the first stage of the movement,
when the technique is only merely a possibility. This changes everything.
Open...
from that opening, go down strait, like that
and there the conditions are perfect.
Secure his hand between your two open hands without grabbing him and bring him to the ground.
If you grab with your fingers and try to bring him down, it is hard.
(resist please)
This is what happens,
but if you keep both hands open...
hold like this, flat handed, it's important, it works better.
If you grab with your fingers, you will act on his strong point and it will be difficult.
But if you use the palms of your hands, it is a lot easier and he will go down.
It is here. That way here, it is no good.
Look, the hand is closed, rolled up upon itself, like that.
After we will do it on the right hand but right now look, he does not fall.
Look once again, it's the same thing.
Like that, go on the side. In the front, it is dangerous.
Here... we push towards him. This knee should go on the other side.
If you do like this, nothing happens. He comes towards you, it is too close, not easy.
We are too close to him,
so we must go further.
It is the elbow that we have to "return" [i.e. : the word "kaeshi" of Kote-kaeshi]
so there are two important points: we must "return" both the wrist AND the elbow.
If you only "return" the wrist, the partner becomes heavy [i.e. no connection between the wrist and the body].
So you must remove these two points, wrist and elbow at the same time.
As a Japanese, I wanted to do something related to my culture.
When did you start?
In the year 2009 in March... no, April.
Did the practice of Daito-ryu have an influence on your life or on yourself?
Yes, a very good one.
More precisely?
My central axis, the axis of my life got stabilised.
On Obi-otoshi, this is how it goes,
grab from below like this.
If you push him, then he won't come and you won't be able to move your feet.
It is totally different as he won't come towards you.
Do it like that, more rigorous, pulling him forward from below.
I feel that Budo is really a part of Japanese culture, which is why I decided to start.
Compared to other martial arts, Aikido particularly fitted my small built.
I understand...
you just talked about the body,
but did Daito-ryu have an influence on something other than physical?
Sure...
the most interesting thing for me is to have met Kobayashi Sensei, to have continued practicing Aikido, and to meet many people through that.
In fact, according to the Budo that we practice, we can learn the truth, and at same time keep our body healthy.
We have to get the partner spining
That is what happens at that moment...
it is a bit like doing shiho-nage...
liek this, just like fr Shiho-nage...
here, the partner is still there, quite stable...
and it is at this moment that we must unbalance him...
from that point.
In fact we don't move much ourselves.
I think we should start by talking about Takuma Sensei.
Which Sensei? Hisa Sensei?
Hisa Takuma Sensei was a student of Ueshiba Sensei and Takeda Sensei.
That being said, Takuma Sensei started under Ueshiba Sensei
in what corresponds today to Yoshinkan Aikido.
So he started like that as a student of Ueshiba Sensei
and trained with him at the Dojo of the Asahi Newspaper. What he taught was not "Ueshiba-ryu"
But it wasn’t called "Daito-ryu" either.
It was in 1938, maybe before.
Impressive!
Yes, perhaps it was even in 1936 or 1937, I am not too sure.
Either ways, Takuma Sensei received his Menkyo-kaiden in 1940 [from Sokaku Takeda].
It is while Takuma was studying with Ueshiba Sensei that Takeda Sensei came over to Osaka to visit,
It seems that he came in order to improve the level of what was taught by Ueshiba Sensei
during the morning and noon classes.
But when Ueshiba Sensei heard that Takeda Sokaku was on his way, he left in haste for Tokyo without even greeting him.
Hisa Sensei therefore stared to train under Sokaku Takeda from that point on.
At that time, the techniques taught daily were all different and they had to remember them nonetheless.
It was quite hard to memorise so they started to keep a photographic record in order to remember them.
This became the series of technical snapshots called "Soden" which can still be studied today.
Actually, Daito-ryu was quite confused and disordered.
So Takeda Tokimune Senseiď [Takeda Sokaku'son] told to his father: "We should classify the techniques a bit better".
Ueshiba Sensei for example had indeed taught using the syllabus that we know today: "Ikkyo, Nikkyo, Sankyo, Yonkyo…"
And if we look at Yoshinkan, it was also these four techniques built and organised in a vertical manner.
But Ueshiba's techniques were a bit different so Tokimune said to his father:
"Father, we should give back Ikkajo its essence and resume the 118 kihon. Wouldn't it be beneficial? What do you think?"
His father answered:
"Some of my students have already obtained the Kyoju-dairi, I don't have much more to teach them, isn't it enough?
Don't they know enough?"
This began the next stage of teaching.
Sensei, you learnt Aikido at the Aikikai Honbu Dojo right?
When was it?
I became the student of Hisa Takuma Sensei.
And while I was training regularly, I was also a student.
I had to use the situation so I opened an Aikido club.
I gathered some students on the one hand,
and thanks to a letter of introduction from Hisa Sensei, I could meet Tokimune Sense and go to his seminars.
Fro, that I went to follow classes at the Yoshinkan and at the Aikikai.
I got that letter of introduction from Takuma Sensei around March 1966
so that I could meet Ueshiba Sensei, Takuma Sensei's former teacher.
Was Morihei Ueshiba Sensei still teaching at the time?
Yes, he taught the first morning class, but I can't remember which days.
And then it was Kisshomaru Sensei.
Kisshomaru Sensei… right...
Yes, Kisshomaru Sensei was teaching the other morning and evening classes
with also the other classes taught by the Uchi-deshi so I could train every day.
And now in during your classes in Tokyo, a lot of students come from an Aikido background to study Daito-ryu isn't it?
Sensei, what do you think about people coming from Aikido to study Daito-ryu?
Yes, as I said before, Hisa Sensei started to learn from Ueshiba Sensei
and he later became a student of Takeda Senseď. There is no incompatibility.
Whether they are Ueshiba's or Takeda's techniques, there is no profound disagreement
because very naturally, Daito-ryu techniques evolve into Aikido techniques.
For these Sensei, there is no doubt that Daito-ryu led to Aikido.
For me it was the same, in Tokyo, because I had obtained an introduction letter to train with Ueshiba Sensei and Shioda Sensei,
I could train both morning classes and the evening class at the Honbu Dojo,
And the the lunch class at the Yoshinkan.
Really? Who was teaching at the Yoshinkan?
It was Shioda Sensei's students, mister Kushida and Inoue.
But Shioda Sensei did not teach anymore, I was too important.
There were also other black belt instructors whose names I have forgotten.
This is where I learnt. In fact, Yoshinkan techniques really looked like Hisa Takuma Sensei's techniques.
The techniques taught at the Asahi newspaper were conform to those taught in Tokyo at the Yoshinkan Iidabashi dojo.
I understand.
At the Aikikai however, it was a bit different.
While I was a student in Osaka, I had setup an Aikido club, part of an organisation
which was in fact a grouping of several universities of Osaka.
So these Kansai universities called us to meet us
as they wanted to get introduced to a permanent Sensei.
And it is Kobayashi Hirokazu who was chosen.
He was one of the post-war uchi deshi of Morihei Ueshiba.
So he was sent on behalf of the Aikikai to Osaka.
Takuma Hisa had been a sumotori and his knees were bad so he could not take the charge.
Besides, I thought that once I graduated, Daito-ryu might disappear from the university,
so I thought that it was best to affiliate with Ueshiba since there was already an Aikido federation.
So I suggested to Hisa Sensei to affiliate the club to the Aikido federation and he agreed.
The technical director for Kansai was Kisshomaru Sensei
but the club was to stay under the direction of Takuma Hisa, ensuring a courteous relationship.
Takuma asked Kobayashi Hirokazu to run the club.
It is at this point that the club went from Daito-ryu to Aikido.
Since Takuma had asked Kobayashi, he said that he did well and that is how it went.
Incidentally, Kobayashi Hirokazu Sensei had learned from Takuma Sensei,
he had studied with him.
So it happened like that and things changed a lot in the club.
Everyone left and went to practice Aikido but I continued to practice both,
I did both Daito-ryu and Aikido.
Kobayashi Sensei, you now come every month from Osaka to teach in Tokyo,
how did you start teaching Daito-ryu there?
I have former students there, including Kawabe Takeshi Sensei,
he wanted to practice Daito-ryu in Tokyo so he asked me if I wanted to help.
In fact, he only taught three or four times, i was really busy...
so I took over from that point.
What do you think about the Tokyo group?
It is quit easy in Tokyo.
Once students grasp the meaning I want to give to my techniques, it becomes easier.
And because I am not very good,
although I did learn a lot in Hokkaďdo,
it is good to think about passing on to future generations.
Thank you very much.